voy a ser honesta con ustedes esta
interferencia de una ranura es bastante
confusa este argumento que les di hace
un momento cuando yo lo escuché la
primera vez se me hizo algo bien raro y
realmente me quedé yo bueno que es lo
que me están diciendo aquí qué quiere
decir esto para mí todo esto no tenía
ningún sentido sin embargo en este vídeo
les voy a mostrar que este mismo
argumento que usamos para encontrar la
interferencia destructiva no nos
funciona para los puntos constructivos y
de esta manera veremos que realmente
esta fórmula nunca nos va a dar los
puntos constructivos no los puede dar
aproximadamente pero no nos lo dará
exactamente porque vamos a verlo en este
momento
nos deshacemos de lo anterior y ahora
trataremos de derivar la fórmula para
los puntos constructivos como lo hicimos
en la ocasión anterior y lo primero que
digo es que bueno aquí cada uno de estos
puntos se va a disfrazar tenemos un
número infinito de fuentes de onda pero
no puedo dibujar un número infinito de
puntos así que de nuevo voy a dibujar
8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y voy a dibujar mi
patrón de interferencia en la pantalla
la representación gráfica aunque
realmente se ven como unos puntos aquí
unas líneas medio borrosas pero la
representación gráfica luce algo más o
menos así
por acá y por acá tenemos un punto muy
brillante justo en el centro y otros
puntos no tan brillantes aquí a los
lados y seguimos teniendo los pero ya no
los alcanzamos a distinguir y ahora
vamos a elegir un punto constructivo
digamos que este de acá aquí tenemos un
punto brillante y si yo tuviera que
adivinar en dónde se encuentra otra
interferencia constructiva pues yo diría
que por acá
en este punto tomo mi onda que está
hasta arriba y digamos que viaja esta
distancia ahora tomo la onda que se
encuentra en el medio de la ranura y
viaja esta distancia imagino mi línea
que va por aquí para encontrar la
diferencia en la longitud de la ruta y
esta es la diferencia en la longitud de
la ruta y cuál será esta bueno para que
estas dos ondas formen una interferencia
constructiva aquí debemos de tener un
entero de lambda una lambda o dos lambda
ya que este es el primer punto brillante
después del punto central la diferencia
en la longitud de la ruta aquí debe ser
blanda una longitud de onda y cuál es la
relación entre esto y el ángulo que
forma este punto con la línea central ya
la habíamos encontrado es esta de la
distancia de por el seno del ángulo
igual a la diferencia en la longitud de
la ruta cuánto va a ser de bueno
recordemos que el ancho de esta ranura
esto de aquí es w cuál será la distancia
de aquí acá pues la distancia entre esta
onda y esta otra onda de acá va a ser
igual a w entre dos entonces nos queda
que w entre dos por el seno
dt es igual para estas dos líneas pues
va a ser igual a lambda
esto es suponiendo que estas dos líneas
interfieren constructivamente en este
punto y si simplificó eso me queda
wv por el seno de theta igual a 2 blanda
así que esto me daría un punto
constructivo y aquí ya estoy konfundida
doble o porsche lo detecta nos da
constructivo
justo acabamos de demostrar que esto nos
da los puntos destructivos recuerden que
la fórmula que acabamos de encontrar es
w por el seno de theta igual a m por
lambda siempre y cuando m sea diferente
de cero pero puede ser 1 2 3 4 5
etcétera
esta fórmula nos da la interferencia
destructiva
y esto es para cualquier m que sea
diferente de cero pero puede ser 1234
incluso puede ser negativa si quieren
encontrar los puntos destructivos aquí
abajo como es posible que estos sean
constructivos buenos son más o menos
constructivos bueno vamos a tratar de
encontrar qué pasa aquí si yo sigo con
este argumento para estos otros puntos
lo que va a pasar y aquí recordemos que
esta fórmula está bien no hay ningún
problema con esto el problema radica en
esto recordemos lo que habíamos dicho
antes estas dos líneas me van a dar
interferencia constructiva y si esto
sucede para estas dos líneas ocurrirá
también para las siguientes será esto
cierto vamos a ver ahora vamos a tomar
este punto de acá y este otro de acá y
vamos y vamos a ver que recorrer la
distancia hasta este otro punto de acá
del momento luce bien
en el mismo ángulo y tienen la misma
distancia entre ellos
esta distancia sigue siendo w / 2 por lo
que me sigue quedando w entre 2 por el
seno de theta igual a mi lambda
mi ángulo es el mismo y tenemos que es
lambda la misma diferencia en la
longitud de la ruta entre estas dos
ondas por lo que estas dos líneas azules
también interfieren constructivamente
así que esto luce bien pero está mal y
en un momento les voy a explicar por qué
vamos a ver estos otros dos puntos aquí
que también recorren esta distancia y
tiene la misma separación igualito que
lo que tenemos aquí arriba estas dos
también serán constructivas y de verdad
será que este punto de m igual a 2 es
constructivo o será destructivo
este argumento falla y falla porque si
yo dibujo mi onda
su ciclo supongamos que estos dos puntos
morados forman una interferencia
constructiva aquí en su ciclo de onda
este es el primero y digamos que este es
el de en medio
este es este y este va aquí estos dos
van a interferir constructivamente ya
que se encuentran en la misma posición
del ciclo que sucede con los dos
siguientes con los azules pues estos van
a interferir uno acá y el otro acá está
en la misma posición ambos por lo que
tendrán interferencia constructiva pero
no necesariamente coinciden con los de
color morado qué sucede con los de color
naranja los naranjas tendrán una
interferencia constructiva ya que
coinciden en la fase pero no están en el
mismo lugar que los anteriores qué pasa
con los demás puntos bueno a lo mejor
tengo estos otros dos y estos dos
llegaron
por acá en su fase estos 2 juntos son
constructivos y aquí pueden ver el
problema aunque estos dos sean
constructivos mutuamente este no es
constructivo con este de acá así que no
se van a sumar al contrario la mayor
parte de ellos se va a cancelar y es por
eso que estos puntos de acá son tan
débiles son puntos muy débiles en
comparación con el punto central porque
no tenemos puntos en donde todos
coincidan necesariamente algunos se van
a cancelar entre sí pero no se va a
cancelar todo completamente y es aquí
donde les dije algo que no es del todo
cierto en la rejilla de difracción
recordemos que con la rejilla de
difracción vamos a quitar esto de aquí
un momento dijimos que la rejilla de
difracción teníamos aquí nuestra rejilla
y por aquí nuestra pantalla e íbamos a
tener muchos agujeros en nuestra rejilla
y dijimos que la rejilla de difracción
era genial porque en lugar de tener
estos manchones medio borrosos en la
pantalla íbamos a tener un punto bien
definido aquí otro bien definido acá
bien definido acá bien definido acá
en ambos lados del centro y con un
espacio entre ellos igual básicamente y
vamos a tener aquí cero
un punto muy brillante y muy cerrado
luego 0 y otro punto brillante y angosto
d después 0 y otro punto brillante y
angosto y la razón por la que en la
rejilla de difracción dijimos que íbamos
a tener estos puntos bien definidos y
brillantes en ambos lados justamente
porque y regresamos a esta parte de aquí
las partes entre estos puntos
constructivos se cancelaban casi
totalmente pero no necesariamente se
cancelan completamente por lo que estos
fragmentos de luz en el patrón de la
rejilla de difracción son tan pequeños y
tan poco pronunciados que no los
alcanzamos a distinguir al menos
comparados con estos puntos si quisiera
dibujar esto un poco más apegado a la
realidad llegaría por acá
definitivamente tendría este pico de
aquí pero después tendría esto
mini picos de luz variaciones muy
pequeñas que realmente no se alcanzarían
a notar y que algunas serían
constructivas y otras serían
destructivas
y lo que yo veo es la interferencia de
una sola ranura es solamente esto
tendré un punto central brillante aunque
no será tan pronunciado porque es solo
una ranura pero seguiremos teniendo
estas extrañas variaciones que
ignoraremos en su mayor parte en la
rejilla de difracción pero que en la
rejilla sencilla si veremos un poquito
más claramente así que aquí no podemos
ignorarlas tanto y debido a que éstas no
se cancelan estas las encontramos aquí
porque éstas no se cancelan
completamente por lo que este argumento
no funciona solamente funciona en el
sentido de que estas dos ondas van a
interferir constructivamente y podremos
emparejar estos puntos para que quizás
sean constructivos pero no todos van a
quedar en el mismo punto de la fase que
es lo que nos daría un punto
constructivo perfecto
y es por esto que es difícil encontrar
una fórmula precisa para calcular estos
puntos y encontrar la fórmula para los
puntos constructivos no es muy sencillo
necesitaríamos un poco más de
conocimiento sobre física por lo que
típicamente en las clases de
introducción en la física no nos van a
preguntar cuáles son los puntos exactos
de la interferencia constructiva pues
incluso estos puntos parcialmente
constructivos también tienen ciertas
cancelaciones lo que sí sabemos con
exactitud es encontrar los puntos en
donde se encuentra la interferencia de
destructiva y si queremos una ubicación
aproximada de un punto de interferencia
constructiva pues podemos encontrar la
ubicación exacta de dos puntos de
interferencia destructiva que sean
vecinos y podríamos decir que el punto
constructivo se encuentra
aproximadamente a la mitad de estos dos
si es que quisiéramos tener una idea
aproximada de su ubicación
puedo imaginarme que algunos de ustedes
todavía no estarán muy contentos con
esto me pueden decir a ver espera un
momento me dices que esta fórmula nos
sirve para encontrar los puntos
destructivos pero acaso este problema
que nos encontramos para los puntos
destructivos también afecta a los puntos
constructivos la respuesta es no no
importa si se encuentran en diferentes
puntos de la fase ya que en este caso
los pares son destructivos se cancelan
si analizamos este argumento para los
puntos destructivos por ejemplo veamos
las ondas moradas en la interferencia
destructiva estas dos se van a cancelar
una va a estar en el pico y la otra va a
estar en el valle y esto nos va a dar
cero el efecto que tienen mutuamente es
de cancelarse por completo así que la
luz de estas dos ondas que llegue a este
punto es cero está completamente
destruida qué va a pasar con los
siguientes dos que son de color azul
estos dos también se van a cancelar
recuerden que este era nuestro argumento
así que no importa en qué parte de su
ciclo llegue el de arriba puede estar
así pero el de abajo va a estar así
lo que ocasiona que estos dos también se
cancelen
estos dos se cancelan ya que se
encuentran desfasados 180 grados así que
esto nos va a seguir dando 0 no importa
en qué punto se encuentren siempre que
estén desfasados 180 grados se van a
cancelar
cada una de estas contribuciones se va a
cancelar y si sumamos muchos ceros nos
va a dar igual a 0 por lo que esta
fórmula de destructiva nos funciona
perfectamente no tendremos el problema
que tiene la interferencia constructiva
es un problema y la interferencia
constructiva porque a lo mejor estos dos
puntos se suman y nos dan un número más
grande pero estos dos puntos azules nos
pueden dar un número diferente y a lo
mejor estos puntos rojos nos dan un
número negativo y si tratamos de sumar
todos estos números diferentes bueno
pues esta fórmula no es tan fácil de
encontrar el sumar ceros es muy fácil
siempre nos va a dar como resultado el 0
y al menos con esto espero haberles
explicado por qué toda esta cosa extraña
no nos funciona aquí y al mismo tiempo
les haya dado una mayor explicación del
por qué esta fórmula si funciona
y confíen más en esta fórmula para la
interferencia destructiva con esto
podemos encontrar sin ningún problema
exactamente los puntos destructivos y
hay otra cosa más que podemos saber y es
el ancho de este punto central este va a
ser ancho y ya que esto nos sirve para m
igual a 1 y el primer punto destructivo
está aquí
esto es ancho de hecho es el doble de
ancho que la distancia entre estos otros
puntos destructivos y qué tan ancho es
esto bueno podemos encontrar el ángulo
para este primer punto destructivo
cuando m es igual a 1 y podemos
encontrar también el ángulo para este
punto destructivo que es cuando m es
igual a menos solo y con un poco de
trigonometría podemos encontrar esta
anchura así que también podemos
encontrar o calcular la anchura de este
punto brillante central y su ubicación
justo en el centro
la ubicación exacta de estos puntos
constructivos no es tan sencilla
aunque podemos calcular su ancho ya que
se encuentran entre los puntos
destructivos y esos puntos destructivos
es justo en donde terminan pero no
tenemos una fórmula exacta para calcular
los picos exactos de aquí aunque tenemos
la fórmula para encontrar los puntos
destructivos exactamente y es lo que nos
piden encontrar típicamente en los
problemas de interferencia de una ranura